let's keep taking call 617 830 for 750
uh who is up next today my name is Ramon
on the Bronx from the Bronx I like it
what which uh are you a 45 guy or a 23
train guy I'm a 2 and the 5 kinda guy Oh
25 alright well that's uh yeah that's a
whole other group of people who is we'll
talk we'll talk about that on different
day what can we do for you Ramon so add
a question of if Donald Trump were to
win and he were to be in office do you
think the republicans in the house and
in the Senate would go along with any of
his crazy ideas at the detriment to them
being may be voted out of office in the
midterms I think that there would be a
split I think that you would see the
opportunists if Trump wins very quickly
the the you will see just coming out of
the woodwork the opportunist who want to
make buddy-buddy with Trump they won't
love the crazy stuff Trump will try to
do but they will sort of couch it all as
hey listen you know we respect the
office of the president and there are
powers afforded to people in different
positions in the Constitution blah blah
blah and they'll just sort of try to
cling on to because the president has a
lot of power if your buddy buddy with
the president in some way that could
have benefits there will probably be
another faction that splits off and and
just really becomes obstructionist
within the Republican Party while trying
to get their policy pass maybe with
moderate Democrats Louis working
together in some way I don't know I
predict that the the Trump that the GOP
Trump obstructionists ours are still
going to have to uh put on that uh that
facade of being totally anti-democratic
and Democrats are terrible and it might
even continue to bash Barack Obama
because why not sure yeah how do you see
it would daddy would that would that
also mean that arm you would have maybe
Ted Cruz's and other obstructionist like
that even still go along with um Donald
Trump even if they
had like their qualms in the past now I
see uh Ted Cruz as maintaining
opposition to trump throughout a trump
presidency I don't know why I just after
what we've seen during the campaign I'm
not sure I see him as being the guy who
jumps on the Trump bandwagon but we will
see or hopefully Ramon we will not uh
thank you so much for the call always
great fear from people in the Bronx
thank you all right take care of Mon
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / tdps the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s